we'll turn to social media and social
media scams and what you can do to
protect protect yourself from online
hackers cryptocurrency scams have
skyrocketed during the pandemic the
federal trade commission estimates that
since october 2020 people ages 20 to 49
were five times more likely to lose
money in those online investment scams
we spoke to a 24 year old mary peplin
who says she thought she was messaging a
friend from high school on instagram but
she claims it was actually a scammer she
shared her phone number and then clicked
on the link that was sent but by then it
was too late
my facebook and my instagram were both
compromised i started getting messages
and phone calls from friends and family
asking me hey mary are you on your
instagram right now asking me for money
i think i had a panic attack i was
mortified i was crying i was upset i did
not know what to do
i tried every
angle i could to get in touch with
instagram i tried to email them i tried
to call them i tweeted at them i was
like please help me they didn't respond
to anything i spent
30 days day in and day out just working
at this trying to get it back from every
angle i could i was overwhelmed with the
amount of messages that were sent to
people that i didn't even know they were
trying to get any money they could from
anyone they probably messaged and
harassed over 500 people this whole
experience was very traumatizing i was
being treated differently by my peers
because they thought you know i'm either
a scammer or i was
dumb enough to get hacked i was just
terrified of you know what damage they
could do to my reputation i think
instagram should have a handle on this i
want them to do something about it i
know the stress and anxiety that comes
with
losing your account and then having your
face be the front of some money scheme
i mean it's awful
in response instagram provided a
statement that reads in part we have
sophisticated measures in place to stop
bad actors in their tracks before they
gain access to accounts as well as
measures to help people recover their
accounts we know we can do more here and
we're working hard in both these areas
to stop bad actors before they cause
harm we're joined now by thomas germain
a technology writer for consumer reports
good morning how are you doing good
thanks for having me so can you explain
what cryptocurrency scams are to people
who don't know yeah so cryptocurrency
scams are really on the rise these days
and it's basically anytime a fraudster
gets in contact with you and tries to
get you to invest in bitcoin or other
cryptocurrency or pay for some kind of
good or service and the bad news is you
really don't have to know anything about
cryptocurrency to get wrapped up in one
of these things they go on your
instagram account yeah yeah i was
wondering how do you spawn they go on
your instagram account they uh reach out
to you over instagram could be an email
or a call there's all kinds of different
ways they can get in touch with you yeah
how can you tell if it's genuine or not
well in general you just want to
there's a couple of different steps you
can take right number one you want to
trust your gut if you have a bad feeling
about someone you're talking to on the
internet you want to listen to those
instincts thomas not everybody has a
good yeah right yeah you've got to get
something else yeah not everybody has a
good gut it's true yeah yeah go ahead
well you also want to be careful about
who you're getting in contact with and
who you're making payments to right
sometimes i'll ask you to send payments
over venmo or cash app in general you
want to limit those to your friends only
and then number three just don't respond
you get a message from someone they say
they're from the government or from your
bank or someone you don't know at all
just ignore it all together this
happened to me last week actually a
friend reached out to me on instagram
and said hey nate let's talk about
cryptocurrency i didn't respond because
i thought it was odd we text a lot why
would he hit me up right in my direct
message and then he said hey um actually
if you could just send me 500
i think we can make a lot of money this
is a true story
it was it was a friend that i knew i
immediately texted him and i said hey is
this you because if this is and you need
money i'll send it to you right and he
said nate that's not me please report um
somebody has taken my account wow so in
that instance do you recommend that
people reach out to the individual that
is reaching out to them that's a great
idea and also you can go and report the
account you click on those three dots in
the top right corner right it's really
easy to do that helps it it does help
sometimes it takes a while but there's
not a lot you can do once that happens
thomas how do they know the name of
nate's friend to reach out to him how do
they get they just find people at random
they reach out to as many people as they
can it's a fishing game
someone falls for it then they're in and
they go from there if they grab an
account then they can search through
their friends and say i'm going to send
them and benefit from the trust when you
think you're hearing from someone you
trust how do you feel about what the
tech companies are doing to respond to
this well i think they could be doing a
lot more in general like it's something
they take very seriously but they're not
putting a lot of time and effort into
helping people and there's a lot of
people out there that are just left in
the dust with no recourse they're trying
to stop bad actors they say i like
you're going forward more fraudsters
yeah yeah thank you so much thank you
thomas we appreciate it thanks a lot